hey Tom how many shots you want this  Chuck cat come on man I'm gonna get you  some shots man  I won't some of you check out this box  non-football bro dominate don't worry it  ain't over yet and you know viet check  up  what he got left here Tom his third  I think you just made a mad Chuck oh no  I love it though man he could take a  joke  [Applause]  Wow way to get $100 for birth capital  thank you baby  oxtail Brooks how about that hey can I  say a few things please you got the  haven't hit a good shine eight hosts I'd  like to speak for a little bit everyone  yes my wife my kids I love you this has  been a yeah hey my wife I love you my  kids I love you I hope you're watching  wouldn't go and get tough the tough get  going boys look at this again  ladies for that this par-5 7th with  Charles just challenging him good  quality Trevor yeah that was something  special right there let that be a lesson  for everybody out there wants to  challenge t be 12